matthew perry and girlfriend molly
herwitz have
split on tuesday the friend star
revealed in a statement to people
magazine
that he and his fiancee had called off
their engagement
quote sometimes things just don't work
out and this is one of them i wish molly
the best
the 51 year old actor started dating the
29 year old literary manager in 2018
and they got engaged in november 2020
at the time he told people quote i
decided to get engaged
luckily i happened to be dating the
greatest woman
on the face of the planet at this time
matthew has received an outpouring of
love and support from his friend's
family recently
it's a very loving tight-knit group
the director behind hbo max's friends
the reunion
ben winston recently spoke out against
quote
unkind comments about the actor and
concerns for his health
specifically his seemingly slurred
speech
here's what he said about matthew during
a chat with the hollywood reporters tv's
top five podcast
he was great i think you know people can
sometimes just be a little bit unkind
and i wish they weren't he was great i
loved working with him i think he's
a brilliantly funny man and uh i thought
he had some great one-liners in the show
and yeah i felt just happy to lucky to
be in his presence and directing him on
something like this
friends executive producer and director
kevin bright also weighed in on the
comments
in a separate interview with the
hollywood reporter quote what people say
is what people say
i don't have anything to say about that
except it was great to see him and i
think he's very funny on the show
but yes i think he's okay he seemed
stronger and better since the last time
i saw him
and excited about going forward matthew
has opened up about his health battles
in recent years
sharing in september 2018 that he had
spent three months in a los angeles
hospital following surgery to repair a
gastrointestinal perforation
he has also previously battled vicodin
and alcohol addiction
but no matter what matthew is going
through his friend's co-stars will
always have his back
something jennifer aniston told et
leading up to the long-awaited hbo max
special
all i can say is that there was
something that was
laid down at the very very beginning
that kind of went into our neural
pathways that we
instantly it was in our dna that we were
family we were going to take care of
each other
you